Oh deej good to see you it's only day
one I know it feels like a day a million
and a half yeah yeah I was up pretty
late last night were you were you
partying them we were partying why might
it what's happening what's happening to
me jeez Louise it's like a work vacation
it's something like that i always think
of III deej like a high school reunion
yeah I but it's like rather than be ten
years it's one year but we all treat it
like it's been a 20 year we all come
here and act like a fool and jump around
and get crazy do you know Alfredo good
to see you I assume that you haven't met
him but no this is it's up you were
wearing that you're wearing like you
like one dreadlock you were wearing it
like an xbox headset you Justin it my
job I did a good point sorry so you
played mayhem clash it did ladies and
gentlemen if you didn't notice this game
Shabazz proffers kind of funny it's us
you know the kind of funny guys coming
here bringing our same show The Flaming
garbage truck were slowly rolling down
the street to gamespot we tricked them
they were like oh you can do live shows
like yeah we can and then I just yell at
Kevin off camera cuz that's what I've
learned is yeah deej your deeds I
emptied your ear from bungie you're one
of my favorites am i yeah you we have
such a good rapport you're a good dude
and you make a great game not enough
people giving you credit for that i
don't think i'm here to talk about this
day students get that's good really good
like we get a lot of credit not enough
how about that we're not getting enough
credit is that I take I take my job as I
take the credit I pass it on to the
people who make the game okay I don't
make the game I play the game and I go
wow that was really great do they get
mad at you about that here's my thought
process is that I I'm gonna eventually
write a letter or maybe just make a
video and send it to developers
privately because I feel bad that I am
quote-unquote internet famous but I'm
famous for talking about what you guys
make sure and so you're famous for
talking on behalf of those guys and so
like there's hundreds of people whose
work have gone into this game but with
something's right or something's wrong
you're the guy they're like what the
hell did sure I'd say I'm notorious more
than victorious and it's an infamous
it's a job we try to reach I
balance it you know it's like I'm there
to help maintain a relationship between
the player and the developer so it's
really about the players of Destiny
understanding who works at bungie what
their vibe is like how we collaborate
together how we bring together
technology and art and imagination to
create awesome experiences for them to
enjoy it's not about taking the credit
it's not about you know my own personal
opinions about the game it's about
making sure that the player feedback
reaches the developers and that the
developer insights and philosophies
reach the player yeah and that's really
what we try to do on bungie.net you know
if we're making appearances externally
on like reddit or neogaf or wherever
wherever we'd be welcome and we can find
people talking about destiny we try to
be in those places because you know I
believe and so too many people at bungie
I believe that video games are art and
art is complete when it's received and
if you want to be a good artist you need
to know your audience and that's been
the best thing about this year's cuz
like i was at e3 last year i talked to
you at e3 last year him right we did we
didn't really know what destiny was we
had our ideas we had our hopes and
dreams but then we released the game you
know we open this brave new world
millions of fans rush in there they
collide with each other they have a
great time they raid they battle each
other in the crucible which you just did
that they do now we know who plays this
game now we can talk to them about that
we can iterate on it based on their
feedback so since last September we've
had this amazing journey where we've
really come to understand who the
guardians of the last safe city are and
to serve them you known to do right by
them all that passion and enthusiasm so
we're pretty happy I mean I question I
get asked all the time is you know I
jumped into destiny for the first time
you know it was too much of a grind for
me is it too late to get it now and it
might know it's not like there's
constant weekly updates they mean the
blogs are you guys post yeah and it's
just it's this game is constantly
evolving it just gets better and better
and like like he just saying like the
feedback I I'm a person's dumped in like
almost 2,000 hours into this game god
damn whatever you hug them are your
tether you can whatever there's a key
knock yourself out of all the gun hey
there it isn't a fist bump the bro bum
hey just and that's why that's why I
still play because it just keeps
evolving
yeah it's just constant thing that just
saw you it gets better and better and
better like more vault space but finally
so he roars bring ever able to speak I
want to know yeah what you guys show
this new trailer yesterday yeah right
hell me all about the new stuff okay the
new stuff is the taken king yes the
taken king is a major expansion to
destiny it's how we're going to kick off
the second year of destiny first years
been awesome you know we've gone on this
sort of partnership with the community
they've created their own voice in the
game they forged their own alliances
clans have you know risen and fallen
world Firsters have come and gone what's
next you know what is the second year of
Destiny going to be like we've got all
sorts of interesting things planned new
adventures new enemies for you to fight
a new subclass for you to level up you
know every single Guardian gets to sort
of grasp that illusive 3rd you know
power and energy in our game you know
like arc solar void power and energy so
every single Guardian has lacked one of
them you know now they just get to reach
out and grab that stuff that's nice
you're gonna need these new powers and
abilities because we've got a whole new
suite of villains and threats for you to
confront and the taken King is all about
that it's about Oryx the taken King an
ancient hive Lord who's coming into our
solar system to avenge the death of
crota he's mad at you he's you mad at me
and you young lady I knew he's not like
the collective we the Royal zactly
exactly one of the interesting things
just kind of like touch up on nights
like my destiny journey so far has been
like you're the Guardian you're going in
your cleaning up shop right yeah
cleaning out the house this was like
wait I'm being hunted like what's going
on here like right like you know like
predator yeah exactly so that's been
really cool to just see that so now how
did it play don't worry about him
looking at you and judging how did it
play I thought it was cool I thought it
was cool seeing like just small little
tweaks here in there like just super is
I jumped in and I was using the supers
and I was like well okay it's very
interesting because like yeah you get
the chest up on like the different
classes now but man it's like it's like
a the Titans have like a hammer you can
toss around i'll do it i'll get like six
kills like this is this is a lot of
kills for a simpler hahaha
also known in you you're running out the
Warlock and you're like let your
fighting everyone and then you have the
hunter the hunters are always like very
like deadly with their supers but now
they have one that's more of a support
which it didn't have before Yeah right
at times like the bubbles and everything
like that but like yeah they have the
the bow that kind of like suppresses the
boat looked awesome yeah the bows a lot
of fun and like you said you know the
hunters have always been just flat-out
offense you know either with the gun or
the blade and now the hunters can come
sort of hang back you know and then you
know put out that shadow shot bind a
whole group of teammates you know on the
opposing team together so you trapped
the enemy team and now they can't move
and they're bound together and then you
or your entire team can move in for the
kill so the hunters never really been a
support role now it is the Titan has
always been up close and personal you
had to commit toe-to-toe you know hand a
hand with your enemy you had to really
risk yourself and expose yourself now
the Titan coming out hang back with
those hammers and just keeping a laying
siege to fortified positions so we're
giving every single Guardian a new way
to fight you know the warlocks are going
to get really up close and personal math
you know the Warlocks almost feel more
like titans they're extremely offensive
you know you get you got that storm
trance you pull the arc energy down it
comes straight out through your fingers
you know it's you are the you know the
classic mage fantasy but very deadly and
very aggressive yeah I like the the
class-based weapons to it kind of feels
like I don't know the weapons kind of
had like this exotic feel right like you
have thus arose version of things now
too young yes the small things Craig you
know I know I'm well aware of the small
things in this game I want to tell you
right now anytime I started hanging out
with our group of friends eventually
they start talking on a level about
destiny that I can't even hang in there
with and I appreciate that i love that
i'm not judging you sure I've seen we
went to this UFC fight a while back at a
Craig baritones apartment and he had all
his friends over there and they started
talking about all this destiny stuff
well the one guy makes is like wait what
did you just mention and he's like oh
it's destiny don't worry and then they
that he immediately inflated he's like
no no I know what you're gonna hang I
want to tell you right then they would a
hominid how many hammers you got wonder
there's going back for that I was like
good lord not to mention that fraid I
was just a god of destiny I mean we had
the Croix de world record at one point
that's fun fastest completion he's a big
deal I don't know if you're aware we are
well we're well aware who you are Fredo
are you really sure Stacy didn't leave
it's okay yeah you're no you're in no
trouble oh I brought up your forum we
will delete nothing from your inventory
all of your exotics are safe now there
will be charged by the end of the day
and you'll have nothing to spend them on
it could be the absolute work all good
all good so what does it mean for you
now to start being able to meet players
like him it's awesome it's awesome you
know last year we were sort of talking
in your platitudes you know like destiny
will have these public events and you'll
have random encounters with people
you've never met and you'll coordinate
with each other and throw in together to
overcome this explosive event and then
you'll move along on your own path and
we're trying to sort of qualify that
forreal you know to kind of cast the
dream for people now we are serving not
sort of an audience in waiting you know
not a fan club but a community a real
player community engaged players who all
have their own story to tell who all
have their own favorite memory from the
game and that is what I have been
waiting to do at bungie since like 2011
ya know yeah I felt like a community
manager for the first time on September
ninth when the game actually launched
because a community needs a place in
common they need to place where they can
go and feel like this is what makes us a
community the fact that we're all bound
to this experience or this environment
you know and the tower is their home now
yeah you know so the players of Destiny
feel like you know like you said you
know you're talking about UFC your over
at someone's house and you're enjoying a
party next thing you know everybody's
sort of like one up and each other you
know it's like I've beaten crow 25 times
yeah you know I beat the vault of glass
on hard yes I have a veck Smith a class
yes I have upgraded it in the house of
wolves you know it's like that is what
makes a player base a community and it's
so awesome to hear them tell their
stories and then to amplify that stuff
on our own channels you know it's one of
the great things i get to do as a
community manager is when someone has
something interesting to say about the
game and they're talking to their own
audience I'm like let me
share this with our audience sure and
introduce them to you so that people
really do feel like they're part of
something cool there are people all over
the world who play destiny you should
come and you should come to out of the
activision booth where we have the way
of rift we have the other crucible play
type on display yes and the end of the
line at the activision booth is this
awesome 30-minute documentary about the
first year of destiny and all of the
things that the community is done is
sort of at a compartmentalized
experience that we've created for the
people here at e3 because you know if
you're a player of destiny you're not
just enjoying a game in a you know
solitary fashion you know there's an
entire world of people who have all done
their own things and found their unique
voice created their unique hero in the
game you know when you share that with
them so where's the real life callahorn
I saw pictures of it that's bro that's
somewhere it's again I want to talk
about you infecting every part of my
life today interview Adam Boyes and he's
drinking this diet coke and that's the
story he leads with yeah he just went
and got a noticed the UH we actually
have a like a locked military-grade case
it says caution explosive projectile we
actually to ship that down here it
contains a gala horn tshirt launcher we
actually to tell our shipping company
okays to waive a case it says explosive
projectile but it's not that alright if
you x-rayed it's going to look like a
viking rocket launcher that's the old
Louis totally could you just trust us
that it's harmless you know hurt anybody
I swear now we have this like gap you
know this like compressed air t-shirt
cannon yeah yeah so there are there
menacing people in the line over the
activision booth with that we bring it
out every once in a while there's only
one person I trust to use it I mean if
you hurt some people some shirts then
you've got to keep seeing video games
you guys don't go camp out again she was
looking for this hammer because he can
shirt you up we can lick you know get
you in the booth you can teach people
how to use the new supers you know right
now i'm using favorite this kind of
focus using his slave labor you can know
Oh i ah we don't I'm gonna free you
Fredo god damn you shot come to the
light I'm gonna light Fredo actually
it's a fun thing we did this year we
have you know the stony booth right over
there where they're playing mayhem clash
and then we've got rift and when you
wait in the line for hours or however
long it takes when you get to the end of
that line and someone puts that
your hand it's either a bungee developer
or a veteran from our community who has
played destiny since the Alpha as one of
the thumb yeah this is the fun stuff
that we get to do at e3 right like it's
everything is a collaboration with our
community yeah you know so the person
who's telling you okay hey you're a
hunter so you're gonna have the void bow
the shadow shot yeah you know try to
bind it try to bind enemies together
shoot him at groups of people that
person has rated more times than they
can remember you know it's not somebody
that we just sort of gave it a t-shirt
instead talk about destiny for the day
yeah all these people like they played
it they know it they've lived it you
know so you can really see that like
with house of wolves right like I stream
destiny all the time that's like my
bread and butter would do and then like
when the house of wolves release you
guys have the light like right the
bungee streams and you have people from
the community right you had other like
top like top in like deci streamers like
Italian and improvement and triple and
these are people that are voices of the
community that everyone watches all the
time right and then here they are now
kind of like with you know hand in hand
with bungie talking about the new stuff
that's coming out and yeah it goes a
long way really when that voice is
important to us you know I can stand up
there in front of a webcam with a bungee
developer and we can say all day long
like I thought it was really smart when
you did that but when we bring someone
in and we get that you know honest you
know sincere reaction you know like whoa
check that out you know it's like that's
what it's about you know it's not about
us appreciating our own work it's about
us serving the player it's about the
players reaction to what we do and it's
about us learning from them you know and
wanting that reaction from then that's
what this past year is about is like you
know people come to our form they debate
the game you know they talk to their
clan they check out their gear then they
come to the feedback form and they tell
us this is what I think here's how I
think your game can be better we have
entire teams of Bungie that read that
stuff you know and cross-reference that
stuff against player data you know we
have a weekly meeting where we all get
into a room and it's like what you see
on the forum I think they want a bigger
vault what are we gonna do about that
you know give it to hear pleas yard room
pls nerf pls nerf the final round sphere
around sphere whelmed you can't get that
role anymore but some people still have
that weapon and it's dirty and searing
them up like one hit anyone
the body dead that's no good that's no
good no no how hard is it though to
separate whiny babies like him with this
the spear thing versus the people who
have legitimate say no whiny baby is
your word yeah that's my word I call him
an engaged player an active player not
all the feedback we get on bungie.net is
what you would call on the polite sigh
yeah of course sometimes it's in all
caps sometimes laced with expect you
know expletives sometimes it has more of
this fair share of exclamation points at
the end but there's truth in all of that
stuff sure you know that is somebody who
has played this game enough to have an
opinion about it and feel strongly
enough about that opinion to come
register on our website and talk to us
about how they're spending their free
time right that's always something worth
listening to interesting I might not go
to their house and knock on their door
and say you know would you like to go
get coffee and you can curse at me at
the starbucks you know as well as anyway
right those that's all the people who
are doing that are the ones who are
angry thinking no one's gonna ever see
it people write angry comments like they
probably all right now in this video and
they never think that I'm gonna go
through and see those comments they ever
think that somebody from yeah from
bungie who spent what four or five years
their life making this part of the game
is gonna see it then be like well that
really hurts my feelings and we do see
it and you know I understand the
Internet can feel like this cold dark
anonymous place and I know there is the
sensibility that in order to be heard in
order to be listened to I have to scream
as loud as I can right I have to
threaten to walk away and hate you
forever to get your love that's not the
way we operate yeah you know we are
actively looking at our forum trying to
figure out who the players of our game
are and how we can serve those people to
the best of our ability you know what do
they like what makes the Med what are
their favorite things about the game
what makes them feel like it's a grind
and makes them want to walk away you
know our world is more interesting when
it's full of interesting players who are
passionate about the shared experience
totally so with the taken King it looks
like there's just a lot of things going
on it looks really meaty can you like
yeah I read on that yeah absolutely so
it's a major expansion we're kicking off
the second year of destiny with this
expansion we're opening up a brand new
destination in your director so you have
a brand new place to go and explore and
conquer they're gonna be all sorts of
new activities in that destination and
it's the dread not
it is a capital ship that belongs to
Oryx it is his spacefaring fortress and
it's full of loot and there are all
sorts of rituals that you have yet to
understand all sorts of ways that you
can instigate shared activities with
your friends it's really not just a new
destination but it's an iteration on how
we build places into our game it's a new
approach to the way we create a space
and then send you there with your
friends to enjoy it in different ways
over and over and over again there's a
new enemy race there's a whole new suite
of combatants for you to fight so take
the combatants you know watching his
eyes dance just watch like it's kind of
funny you do it's coming in September
September 15 right around the corner yep
yeah not far wrong so I why wait so long
to announce it why not announce this
months ago what the height train bill
down the hype train right yeah it just
runs you right over haha you know we
wanted enough time to set people's
expectations as to what this thing was
and not so much time that we spoiled
every secret to keep the conversation
rolling so in September you know people
are still enjoying the house of wolves
enjoy the rest of the summer if you've
never played destiny and this looks fun
you know we're giving people a chance to
jump in begin their adventure you know
join us in this living social world join
the party and then on sep tember 15th
the taken are the new dark army enslaved
by Oryx mutated and twisted by the light
sent back to our dimension to exact
revenge on the Guardians in the last
safe city on you on you specifically and
me and you and anyone else all the
Guardians all of the Guardians yep the
Vidocq we have out today is entitled no
legend is safe so that's that's good
that's a good time I like that one
that's a good line I appreciate that
here's what I want to know yeah your III
games out you're living it getting all
the feedback having a great time what
you talked about it what it was you said
it was 2011 you've been work 2000
aaliyah in 2011 I ran away from home I
came out to work for bungee I had been a
player of Bungie games and a vocal
member of their community for almost a
decade and I didn't even know what
destiny was yeah I just trusted bungee I
loved their creative process and their
personality and their sense of humor
about themselves so
I came out to join that team to help
them tell their story about this new
thing they were working on whatever it
was going to end up being yeah and since
then I've just sort of been watching
destiny kind of come together and watch
people become more aware of it and now
as you said it's a thing all right so I
was going somewhere with that question
but Destin llegara from ign.com is a
proud gonna come here and get up here
yea big ya big jerk well you're not miss
you ask your question talking to
alfredos Mike and Angela wish on the
couch kissa kissa murs about the level
cap what's the new level cap he says
there's a bunch of rumors we're gonna
have to let those be rumors for now Oh
yep yep thanks destiny later effin that
was I've been buying I thought your give
us a scoop IG and let me down I can't
believe it after all these years so my
question then yeah we're there dark
times during that you know 2011 you said
you finally get to feel like a community
manager last September yeah sure where
their dark times is like what are we
even doing or concerns here so I think
there was always a lot of hope you know
that what we were creating was going to
be special that it was awesome we're
always excited about the potential for
destiny obviously anything that you're
working on especially when you're
embarking on something that's brand new
yeah you know there are moments of
adversity there are moments of doubt
personally I've never played a game that
has the you know the damage numbers you
know the player feedback the end gift of
destiny so all of a sudden when math
started to shower and rain down out of
the beautiful moving painting the
destiny ago I had a personal emotional
crisis but now i can't imagine playing
the game without them yeah i mean i need
to know when I'm scoring a critical hit
I need to know if I'm using the right
weapons against these enemies so bungees
always been really focused on giving
good player feedback to the people who
are you know immersed in these
adventures so understanding that this
experience was sort of evolving and
developing over time and a new build
would come online and all the sudden
guardians are dancing in the tower you
know people have guns here like you know
like no this is this is a hardcore
fantasy about warriors they would never
dare devil is like they would celebrate
its a bright hopeful future so you know
what they're just drinking their mugs
exactly exactly i got another flag and
you know but we are you know it's all
about a collaboration at bungie you know
the creative process is just this this
collision
art and science and there are all these
endless debates about what's the best
experience for the player and you know
seeing those debates happen either in
conference rooms you know or over email
I mean we are fans of our own game and
we are as committed to making that
experience great as anybody who would
say let me in the front door bungee and
I will sort this out tomorrow you know
like we are invested in this so seeing
those guys go head-to-head with each
other seeing these developers have you
know like polite but very committed and
impassioned arguments about what destiny
should be I mean being a fly on that
wall you know has been it was a real
treat for me as a fan and as a player it
was a lot of fun DJ I love you I love
you for making time to come by however
you two love each other he loves my name
is ladies and gentlemen destiny the
taken hangs out September 15 everybody
get ready find Alfredo on Twitch he'll
be playing it